I want to start today by trying at least to
run some interference and introduce some facts
into the wild.
Disinformation really is what it is, disinformation
and ignorance and talking points that are
spreading about crime in the United States,
because there are actually some, I believe,
well-intentioned people, including people
on the left, who are falling for some of these
talking points and are ending up in places
where they certainly shouldn't be.
And one of the things that can become difficult,
particularly right now, is that one of the
techniques that the right uses is to continually,
you could say, move the goalposts.
You can say to get Gallup, which is just to
throw a whole bunch of stuff out, making it
hard to refute each piece.
But if you did refute each piece, you would
realize there's really nothing there.
And the area where I'm going to focus on today's
crime, because in the wake of the George Floyd
protests, in the context of calls from some
on the left to either defund or abolish the
police in a broader context, were most most
of the left wants to reform.
You're starting to hear all of these subsequent
steps being taken to get to Joe Biden will
cancel all police and your kids will be killed
as a result of it.
Right.
Like, that's where they want to end up.
There's all these intermediate steps.
And one of those steps is crime is going up.
There's more crime right now.
And they talk about this in the context of
Portland and Chicago, often by playing, you
know, 30 second clips of this or that thing
happening.
So we absolutely have to go step by step.
So first and foremost, if we're going to talk
about whether defunding police once Joe Biden
does, it will do X or Y to rising crime rates.
We've got to figure out, is that actually
Joe Biden's plan?
Would such plans, if they existed, actually
be successful?
But most importantly, is crime going up right
now?
And crime rates in the United States on a
year to year basis have been declining.
That is the first fact we have to introduce
here, because the entire conversation stems
from that, despite the fact that we have more
and more people living in the United States
over time.
Actual crime rates for things like violent
crime, robbery, property crimes.
It has all been declining on a per household
basis.
When you survey people and you ask them, do
you think crime has increased in the United
States from last year?
Almost every year, more than 50 percent of
the people in the United States believe that,
yes, crime has actually gone up.
So crime has been going down since the early
90s.
People mostly believe crime has been going
up OK.
That's step one.
Now, there are a whole bunch of other details
and complications that warrant some more exploration.
So let's do a couple of them before we move
on.
For example, some types of crime might be
up one year, even in the midst of a downward
trend or some types of crime might be up one
year even when other types of crime are down.
So as an example, in 2020, murder is up slightly,
but a whole bunch of other crimes are down.
And over time, all of these types of violent
crime are down.
So you would have to decide, can I really
make any relevant observation in one year
about, well, murders up, but rape and robbery
or down and arson is up.
But burglary and sexual assault or whatever.
Right.
So overall, crime rates have been declining
for a long time and they continue to decline.
It's also important to remember that not all
crimes are reported to police.
So any time we're looking at something that
depends on reporting to an authority, you
have to consider that the records may not
reflect reality at equal rates.
So as an example, which many on the right
don't like.
Sexual assault is notoriously under reported.
However, that doesn't really fit into their
narrative.
If they want to make it seem as though crime
in general is underreported, you really have
to start with sexual assault, which they don't
seem particularly willing to do.
Then you have other crimes, crimes like vandalism
and public intoxication, which arguably should
not even really be a crime, which certainly
are visible in that you see graffiti or a
broken window or whatever the case may be.
But those are not the serious violent crimes
that were really mostly talking about when
we talk about how police should be reformed.
So that gets us to what's going on today since
the George Floyd protests have started.
We've been hearing defund the police.
We've been hearing abolish the police.
We've been hearing reform.
We've been hearing just fund the police blindly.
Give them as much money as they want.
We've heard every combination of things.
The majority of the left, including Joe Biden,
is talking about reform.
It could include reallocation of funds to.
Taking funds away maybe for militarization
while increasing funds for training.
As one example.
But it doesn't really matter in terms of the
crime we're seeing now, because remember all
of the discussions about defunding, abolishing,
restructuring, all that stuff.
It's in the future.
It hasn't happened yet.
And yet still, you have people like Donald
Trump himself and his acolytes tweeting videos
of things going on now in Portland or Chicago,
saying this is the future of the country.
If Joe Biden is elected president.
Hold on a second.
First of all, that's Trump's America right
now.
So to say this is what's going on now and
this is what would be happening even more
under Joe Biden, you then have to see what
is it that Joe Biden would do that would exacerbate
this.
And there actually isn't anything.
But it also ignores that none of these abolish
or defund things have become a reality.
So they are arguing we are seeing more crime
in cities because police have been defunded
by Democrats.
The reality is crime continues to go down
and nothing has been defunded yet.
There have been some conversations in certain
places about how might we reduce funding to
police in some places.
You know, the Northampton, Massachusetts,
is a place where the show started, where there's
been this discussion.
There's been a decrease to the rate at which
police funding will increase.
If that makes sense.
But all of this stuff is in the future.
So you certainly can't blame a future, possible
changes to police funding for current increases
in crime, particularly when there have been
no such increases today.
There have been discussions about do we change?
Who responds to certain types of nine one
one calls when they when they relate to homelessness
or mental illness as an example.
OK.
Those discussions have been had.
There are some places that have started to
look at making some of those changes, but
these policies haven't yet been put in place
when it comes to defund or abolish.
I don't think that they are going to and Joe
Biden certainly doesn't support them.
So when you look at this broader context,
you do have to ask, why are people falling
for the idea that crime is up?
And this actually takes me back to my days
as an undergrad at the University of Massachusetts
AMR's, where Michael Morgan, who's been a
guest on this program, studied this extensively.
Erica Ashar also studied this.
And both of those interviews are on the YouTube
channel.
There's often this assumption and we see it
after mass shootings.
We see it after a lot of things that violence
in the media and in popular culture, in movies
and video games makes people act violently
in the real world.
Now, by and large, that doesn't seem to be
true.
It if you look at the scholarship on this.
It's certainly possible that people already
predisposed to be violent in the real world
might be triggered to act in a particular
way based on things they consume in violent
video games or movies.
But that's a small, small portion of the population.
By and large, we have not found that violent
video games or watching violent news or whatever
makes people violent in the new in the real
world.
However, what does seem to be the case is
that seeing violence on the news and in media
may make people more afraid, and it makes
people believe that the world is more dangerous
than it is.
And in fact, when you look at local news and
you realize, wow, murder is down over the
last 30 years, all of these violent crimes
are down over the last 30 years.
But the representation in media is identical
or has even grown because of this.
If it bleeds, it leads ideology.
It makes sense that based on watching news,
people would believe the world is more dangerous
than it is.
People would believe there is more crime than
there actually is.
So what you have right now, in part thanks
to the Trump administration, is this use.
It's all based on getting Trump reelected.
And we're going to deal with that a little
bit more later in the show.
You have a lot of discussion of very rare
individual incidents that are happening in
the shadows of mostly peaceful protests.
But the takeaway we have to remember is that
crime rates have been on the decline since
the 90s and there certainly has been no defunding
of the police yet, which you could blame for
nonexistent crime increases that they claim
exist.
Now, one other thing that I think is important
to think about, and that's the war on drugs
and prison populations.
Some will say clearly there is more crime
because people are in prison for committing
crimes more than ever before.
There are more people in prison right now.
So clearly, there's more crime going on.
Just because there are more people in prison.
Doesn't mean that the streets of the United
States are more dangerous from a violent crime
standpoint.
If you add things to the list of stuff that
will get you put in prison, you would expect
that more people are going to end up.
Prison, if you put in place mandatory minimums
or if judicial discretion is used to sentence
people to longer prison sentences.
You can see prisons more full, even if violent
crime is on the decline in general society,
which it is.
So it's really important not to fall for that
propaganda because at every level there is
to go back to the beginning.
There is a gift, Gallup going on where a whole
bunch of stuff is thrown out.
Crime is up.
And it's crime because Paul is.
It's up because police have been defunded.
And Joe Biden would do more of that.
You've got to break it down.
Is crime up?
No.
Have police been defunded already in a way
that would even relate to what we're seeing
right now?
No.
Does Joe Biden want to defund the full police
if if he becomes president?
No.
Every single one of the premises is wrong
and they count on because they don't have
the facts on their side side.
They count on you not knowing the facts or
you not checking the facts and ending up having
to argue on the merits.
And when we accept the facts and debate what
should be done, we're missing the fact that
the premises are all wrong.
Hopefully this is useful when we see everything
from Don Junior's tweets to discussions in
right wing media and on the Internet about
these issues.
Go and look at whether the premises make sense
and check out.
In this case, they don't.
Starting with crime has been on a downward
trend for decades in the United States.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at Deas Pacman.
We have a lot happening this week.
This is the month of the 15 year anniversary
of the David Pakman show.
Can you imagine that?
And I'll talk to you later on in the month
about what we're going to do.
The exact date is in the second half of the
month.
But a very, very exciting month.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.